do you ever worry about your mental
health did you take step to protect it
to uh
yeah to like for the long run to make
sure you have the mental strength to go
on yes weirdly enough the best thing for
my mental health was giving in to my
innate nature to work and the most
depressed I get is when I try to
restrict it and like I don't work
weekends so I don't work this day what's
best for me is just to work when I feel
like working and then just not work when
I don't like and just have no
constraints because there are just some
nights where I don't want to sleep and
for whatever reason I feel compelled to
go all night whatever like just do it
you know do whatever you want it's what
I tell my like working brain
um and I just give in to it and I feel
that's where I feel the happiest and and
then um you know it's typically like
when I'm really in The Grind Mode it'll
be like seven or eight days and just
non-stop going going and then it's like
oh I'll realize like oh I need some
recharge time and then go [ __ ] binge
a season of anime yeah but listen to you
but that's the thing like people will
tell you don't work weekends or don't do
this or don't work past this or Baba
I'll give you all these constraints but
for me and it's unconventional I just
give in to it I think there's something
really to be said for that I I try to
surround myself with people that like
what I don't when I pull an all-nighter
they don't go like you should get more
sleep there's a reason I pulled that
all-nighter like if I'm really
passionate about something they say they
basically encourage it because I I have
no problem getting sleep and getting
rest
um what I need in my life is people that
encourage you to kind of keep going keep
going with the thoughts that you're
passionate about normal people They
don't want that life and they probably
shouldn't it's not good for you
um but yeah is if you hang around people
like just whatever different people
you're gonna feel crazy and it's gonna
wear on you whereas if you're around
similar people it just it's so much
easier like if you
you know
um I've started weightlifting more and
like one thing that's helped is just
having Jack people around me because
they naturally just eat healthier they
do like they naturally just have
freaking grilled chicken and all this
[ __ ] and high protein meals and it's
just like easier for me to just
piggyback and be like oh can you just
order me whatever you're getting uh and
they're like I gotta go to the gym and
I'll be like oh [ __ ] I'll just join you
you know and it's like it's just it's
cheat codes you know I mean just
surround yourself with people that you
want to be and it makes it like 70
easier in my opinion it's like that is
the cheat code to life
um and I wish I obviously your audience
is definitely a lot older but you know
to the older people listening like if
you have are in a place of mentorship
for someone younger or have influence
over younger people you should really
try to drill that in their heads like
the people are there around 100 dictates
the outcome I would not be on 120
million subscribers if I didn't find uh
when I was around a million I had a
couple friends that were just also
Psychopaths you know I outgrew them but
at the time it was great and I wouldn't
be where I am today if it wasn't for
them
um and just all along the way the
friends that I hung out with had such a
dramatic impact on wearing them like I'd
probably have 80 million less
subscribers you know if it was if I
wasn't so strategic about hanging out
with people that I add value to and they
also add value to me so the advice for
young people would be to
be very selective about the people you
saw yourself so selective it's it's
crazy like Chris you know he's I I he's
really funny and that's why he's great
for the videos and part of why he's so
funny is he consumes copious amounts of
cartoons and just funny content and so
I'll find like when I spend more time
with Chris I'll start just quoting these
weird cartoons and shows and like my
speech will literally change and just
after like a week of spending more time
with him it has like it's like that
quick out of effect you know now picture
that over the course of years I mean
yeah it has such a huge influence like
pluck one of their friends out and
hypothetically put me in there and yeah
you know there's no doubt if they're
trying to become a content creator there
are odds of success is 10x right
obviously you can't do that but you got
to find your closest version of it and
just be selective yeah but this also
applies not just the younger to older
people to agree but they it's it's even
more I like when I was a teenager I just
you know I couldn't relate to many
people I just I was like a [ __ ]
freaking nature because no one was
obsessed with building businesses or any
of this kind of stuff and so like back
then you know that advice would have
been helpful maybe not that particular
but just knowing that there are you know
it's not that you're a freaking nature
you just haven't found people that have
the same interests so the task is not to
feel sorry for yourself or somehow
change yourself it's more to finally
find people you fit in with yeah yeah
assuming which you know you're not
getting comproment uh like assume it's
not something bad right like if your
hobby is shooting things you know or
shooting things you shouldn't be
shooting you know don't find people that
encourage that but
outside of that for sure uh actually as
an answer to what is the best advice
someone ever gave you you said you're
crazy until you're successful then
you're a genius 100 all along the way
people gave me so much
you know advice on why I shouldn't be
doing it why I'm crazy every step of the
way people wanted to tell me why I
shouldn't be doing this and should get
alive should stop being too obsessed
everything everything under the book
um and then once I'm successful those
same people are like tank
you're a genius wow you really you
pulled that off those are probably the
same people that will give you advice
now you're the most successful video
creator of all time stick to that
anytime you want to do something new
right yeah uh they'll they'll like
pressure you not to do the
um you know feastables or or mobile
gaming or whatever lays Beyond yeah it's
funny how people don't well honestly
they're the type of people I just don't
talk to anymore
I don't even know what they have to say
now so most people on the team are like
yes and they're like whatever the idea
you got they they're with it no it's
weird we actually have a my team pushes
back on me pretty hardcore
um which I want I don't want Yes Man and
yeah they're they're like uh they're
James you know the CEO who helped me
build all this um he's very adamant like
we're not yes men and and he trains
people to really think for themselves
and even when I give them orders like
really think like is this optimal is
there context or information Jimmy could
be missing that I can provide that could
help him make a more updated decision
like I'm not
um God you know what I mean like I'm
human and I make errors and so don't
take what I say that's the Bible
so even like in the brainstorming and so
on they can they can push back yeah you
can see it like Tyler anytime I said
something he would give me feedback and
push back which is what I want I don't
want him just to be like yes you're
[ __ ] genius good job Jimmy you know I
don't need that you know I need negative